good morning gamers okay Jack and I are
about to record we're on the survival
world what Jack doesn't know is that I
spent an hour setting up traps pranking
my minecraft partner epically if you
think this is not fair
remember to two or three episodes ago
Jack pranked me okay
I was digging one of the trees and he
removed the ground so I couldn't reach
far high enough so therefore I have set
up a couple traps now how do you trap an
Irish person well it's simple you leave
signs let's say potatoes this way our
first trap is actually my favorite one
it says pull for potatoes I put it far
in so he will actually go in all the way
he will fly up there a piston will stick
out so here we'll be stuck in a room
full of obsidian sadly you can't push
obsidian because otherwise he'd be
filled with an entire room but it you
know I'll just show you so you pull this
and the floor activates underneath for
you and he's gonna be super confused
he's not gonna know what to mine and
then I'm gonna tell him hey mind the
floor jack and he's gonna be like oh
okay cool and then by the time he
figures out to mine the bottom he's
gonna fall all the way down there's
water don't worry there's water on the
ground because I want to prank him on
more stuff now that's trap number one
wait that's not great oh god I almost
fell in my own trap let's reset it now
that's just trap number one baby we have
another trap here that says potatoes
this way of course dummy dumb dumb is
gonna go for it
he's gonna fall in and you know what
he's gonna think oh that's a funny prank
you did there you got me good I'll just
jump out a little does he know the whole
thing is gonna blow up he's gonna think
this trapdoor is what activates the
floor but little does he know this one
actually activates that's right dynamite
baby
oh he's calling me oh god okay I don't
have time to show all the traps damn it
oh god he just joined
I also have another trap that says look
down for potatoes he's gonna look down
and before I realize I'm gonna push him
in then we also have potatoes potatoes
this way he's gonna follow it
I swear so many epic potatoes potatoes
over here jack
almost there sweet potatoes so close
okay
so there's a there's a creeper down
there as soon as he looks down it's
gonna blow up in his face and I named
the creeper potato I know
genius okay there's one more trap but I
can't he's gonna think I'm up to
something
shop gamer hey oh hello
hey hey Oh Susan tuck hey can you hear
me in the game yeah I installed within
the graphics with good shaders and I can
barely recognize the game now I'm back
at the base of you me the coordinates oh
okay he's stuck forever now Jack this is
what he gets for attacking me he wants
to stay he wants to stay Oh sad I can't
find my dog Jack this is so sad wait
really yeah I don't know where he is I
don't know should we get a sleep seed oh
sure okay
oh good night gamers okay I have a I
have a surprise for you Jack I see a lot
of no not that
well as you can see there's also
potatoes this way Jack actually maybe
maybe not this one first do this this
one first actually you know yeah potato
potato
do you smell do smell potatoes this way
check your trap now coward yep yep don't
worry Jack Alex don't worry you can just
dig down to go back oh wait did the
ladder catch you no you can't it's okay
I damn it
I put the ladder there to be nice to you
so you could fall all the way oh wait oh
there's a missing ladder here oh no I'm
stuck okay it's fine Jesus cheaper leap
I thought I was so proud of it a good
old friend in Minecraft helped me dig
out I don't ever shovel like I was
supposed to prank you and then now I
trap myself as well alright well there's
more okay oh look with this look down
for potatoes what better look down
better look down for Porteous I love
those not there No Oh over here oh
that's what you get Jack
oh no you're gonna die say your last
prayer Jack wait enjoy your last potato
Jack hey
[Laughter]
saves it what impossible I have the
power of God and my craft oh did you get
the ladder yep no he said now I'm gonna
destroy your message no my lol no ho
stole I'm gonna write a new message for
you okay okay come back up sorry I'm so
sorry about that there's different
potatoes all up over here they're gonna
be potatoes at the bottom of one of
these there's patek there will be
potatoes at one of them yeah of course
[Laughter]
no I spawned at the very first base now
what the sheep they're what they're
sheep here in spitting back to doghouse
he likes you have to stay imprisoned yes
this way you're safe this way you like
little tiny doll stuck in house you
escaped when we find the other dog I'm
sorry sorry Jack there's no more there's
no more traps I'm serious I thought I
get you wait wait Oh Oh what I didn't
place that that's so crazy good tape
potatoes this way what
look down for potatoes that went so well
last time I got so many potatoes his
name was potatoes you saw the three of
them potatoes
Rizzo's but can you solve the fourth one
to get the real treasure
I smell down in the mines perhaps down
in the mines perhaps potatoes down in
the mines perhaps epic potatoes
you got to go with your smell on this
one there's some sort of history lesson
to be taught here is there no science to
guide my way I think you were close Oh
potato there's a way to save you Jack do
you see the lava there's a way to save
you tell how much you love potatoes and
they will save you
you're say you're saved
there's one more little piece huh okay
you're fine
wow that was close
congratulations jack you solve all my
traps potato reward is is waiting oh
stop stop my stop stop stop I stop I I
sit with dog hello did any of these
actually work the way they were intended
the creeper one did you solved all my
riddles it's time for hey stop potatoes
oh there's potato layer oh there it is
there's the bird hold on invader Irish
invader
look look Jack potato right over there
you're fine you're fine it was just a
fine a little prank it's okay yeah don't
eat potatoes Lester focus on hmm very
curious I always have one heart look
Jack look taters
you're so happy dude okay prank epically
that was epic we would shovel I'm back
to spawn now how does anything work what
the sheep why why this happened why I'm
back to spawn well now we're even
are we yeah remember that one time you
pranked me I was cutting down the wood
and you removed the floor underneath me
yeah now we're here I know it's cheap
chop ready to sleep ding ding ding ding
ding ding ready to play normally if
they'd sir I have my inventory that was
awesome
I got you good right I got you good
right you were pranked epically books
that I can't stop any chanting shot
Frost Walker I will put frost walk
around like pants dude I can't do that
has to be dudes usually I put lapis next
to that enchantment thing I should put
like a little bear little bear an extra
day in Chapman and that's how I get it
is it daylight yeah what our epic
pyramid
I see oh yeah I'll play some torches so
they stop stop dammit
let's go to the air for ascends Mill
potato anvil boy if you destroy an
emerald latest destruction
shoot shoot it's gone what's happened to
potato the creeper he was my friend he
was my best friend we grew up together
he was my child where where oh all right
we should find some horses this is we
should actually don't worry about name
tagging just worry about having some
wheat I have some of he needs him shoosh
what are you doing my dog nothing he
likes it it's like massage for him oh
look he's smoking a fat one wow he likes
so much
we must show him we're superior nothing
nothing
[Laughter]
where did you learn how to do that
school I learned in school
wait wait wait wait this is all wrong no
no course isn't even rare hurt did you
pull white wool in here then sorry
smelly brain my brain does not smell huh
you couldn't possibly know it's smelling
pretty you guys I can see okay now we
look like we're so much Richard I spread
the wealth through myself wow we so rich
let's go out fun horse horse horse horse
curse yours
yes yes yes test dude we're being raided
no oh my god okay remember this awesome
okay epic remember detective
insult epic style stinky brain smells
oh I smell it from here smells like dead
potato
wow so embarrassing your mom must be
like poopy your mom must have been like
no thanks
damn Maya he is a savage dude look at
sitting there in his house he doesn't
need it doesn't need actual nutrition
wait should we sleep sleep first
is it getting late I can't tell with
this Mon they will know that we defeated
them before if I put better up with
better yes sleep sleep oh my god sniper
sniper
where are they okay we have perfect
where's your Triton's dude how I fell
then you little got the achievement for
pushing it's okay we're two of us we
couldn't possibly lose that's sting the
[ __ ] star there
that's not our Fox is it no it ain't
blip blop its blip dude they're in our
farm another farm
[Music]
oh they're coming wait I see them
through the wall what what are we a
glitch oh of course the there in the
sacred smoke era smoke but protect the
bells of all cost I thought of course
what if a Ravager shows up and destroys
our pyramid we must protect it off
what's the ravager Oh a peck the Mount
stay away this is like when Kendall and
gimbley was at Helm's Deep and they were
like don't come in oh god I forgot how
much damage this guy do
oh my traps my traps of course very
serious oh he saw my protector funny
bunny god I'm gonna me oh he took money
we're rich now we need a trapdoor here
oh god I have to use the sacred chapter
Oh No smoke signals they escaped
okay we're saying this is epic Swedish
and Irish men defend Europe uh-oh here
comes ravager I can't see anything with
his mod it's so dark I see the pyramid
is like hacking I see through that's
because they bring the barrel and you
can see through the walls but if you do
that are you serious do it again I
thought you were joking oh now we work
spells before wait what
oh so you can find them Oh God there's a
lot of them ouch ouch this is an actual
viable strategy did we break minecraft I
think you hit sorry real enemy was
within all those in the bad this is when
badness there anymore food
yeah throw potato thank you two
remaining one of them is the big thing
let's see him sniff him out yes our
first line of defense blip blop where
are they bring the Bell and ring the
bell
oh not good
oh they're underneath us oh we're gonna
how do we have to get no I think we're
just gonna have to get the witch okay I
grow a horse and you add grow what if
you get them down here yes okay I push I
push it was perfect
I push push push push here on potato
farm Oh God Oh keep running keep ready
to keep running out push push he's not
gonna change to me right okay he
definitely changed to me when I hit him
well okay okay no no shoot Chu Chu Chu
Chu - I have to eat potato that's not
good and now and you know blip blop bad
okay oh nice
okay now now we use epic strategy
against the last okay I used fishing rod
okay I can fish it I'll fish to pull it
down go go out there soldier I only have
two hurts get out there okay endless
potatoes an ocean potato heaven potato
each star look up represents the
potatoes
okay where is he
okay okay I'll be in there I'll be in
position for the fish okay I got him I
got him I got him I got him
oh I almost got hot damn okay and here
Anton ready to go wait oh God you get do
another life through another lap keep
running it's fine it's fine
no okay I do it myself he doesn't like
he doesn't care about me
Oh God he cares now oh god he does a lot
of damage oh god he's a lot faster than
he looks dang it I miss stinky don't go
too close
stinky think he's gonna fall eventually
L equals L I save you I save you just
kidding can Oh Oh No okay I have a new
plan grab a bucket let's get some lava
we cook tonight boys we're using the pro
strats speed run
I think I said something similar and
you're like oh it sounds like Cartman
and then here we are
oh you didn't have the achievement okay
let's go let's go gamers let's go
chip-chop gamers okay one corner each
maybe you do that corner to do the other
eye remember if we can't hurt him
burn coward burn in three years he was
gonna take a lot of pain little scare
the boy pee pee pants whoo that was good
that was evil unlike its ending many
waves I died on the safeness I'm full
health man epic the what
oh the else he's running he's running
wait there's more god oh I don't have
enough potatoes yeah we were supposed to
be a peaceful episode we were supposed
to get horses oh yeah you're right
well it happened for a game right okay
ring Bella where are they oh damn
Hue's there's a lot of them we have to
take out the witches because otherwise
they get left are you getting the witch
okay I'll supervise from above
I make sure tactics work above tactics
supervise me um shoot kill okay I'll
drop down look on my sword they buffed
me dumb witch Oh swore yeah just don't
tell you - OH
killed three witches what did you do
typical Irish behavior what did I
single-handedly take this one come on
Jack I killed what where there's two
more and I weakened that witch well you
were supervising me I was supervising
yes there's one remaining did they fall
in our traps or something I've know they
might have spawned a little bit further
and never made it in so they came from
over here right this way
listen you see really here you see your
Irish ears yes oh oh well those are not
that nice yeah it's we're killing it
dude back to the pyramid I've been there
many times arms
alright there you go back my name Oh God
the pyramid has been all run to the base
how Oh God Oh God not those they have a
conjurer oh oh my boy
Oh Oh the Revengers here don't like
these bird things I hate them
oh god they got me
they're called fixes I guess so oh god
they're so annoying
okay oh god they do so much damage ah
can't you live wax dude we suck do not
suck they take half rails okay I just
kill which maybe that's source no there
now well you still have to kill them oh
my god did you do a lot of damage oh did
you say do do before you die oh you got
it nice okay there's one more vex please
help me you see it I think okay I tank
yeah that's teamwork AC stuck there no
oh you made the epic oh wait he's stuck
there he can't climb fence about the
cows though I go in epic not afraid I
went sick of Mon yeah thank you thank
you you have some loop it worked okay
alright that was a great episode thank
you guys for what but on the morning
gaming time for sleep sleep sleep sleep
you haven't tried to persuade me later
today after 50 million our troops match
oh yeah
here we go just now it's still relevant
just down a bit